hello jewelry kitty where did you get
this those are adorable it's the cutest
ever no I was just being nice
oh that's fine I don't care it is okay
this is uh this is Jake versus MIMO um
I'll just put it out there right now I
usually hate these kind of stories where
someone's being framed or forced to do
something and they can't tell someone
they just drive me insane because you
kind of know what's gonna happen and
then you're just kind of going through
this plot and I always say what's like
wow there's gotta be some way just
personally it drives me nuts but me now
is adorable cutest little thing
I think there's I get a big laugh when
you have you know like a little kid
voice saying something that's like
really gruesome or really mean that cast
especially if it's a real kid and that
just really cracks me up but you got
yeah you got wildberry princess who
lives in this very strange place that I
wish I could tell contestant or
something it looked more like a
slaughterhouse yeah yeah there's even
one where it's like a bowl and some
other animal than just like a chainsaw
next so I'm like the hell goes on here
so I guess that's her Kingdom or
something I don't know and somebody's
gonna try to assassinate her and so she
calls on Finn and Jake and it turns out
it's me mal with this tiny tiny little
cat who wants to get to the guild of
assassins and hides inside Jake's nose
and threatens him with poison or
actually put the poison in him and says
that she'll let it live if he kills the
if he kills the well fairy princess
which is like what doesn't she like
let's go say why doesn't she do it but I
guess because he knows yeah and then at
the very end she gave him enough to kill
a dog 50 times his size and so he turns
into a dog 55 plus one that's eyes just
as what really is I thought that was
very funny
that's a clever way out of that um and
yeah like as I'm usually not bad these
stories but I just love me about that's
all I got I think she's just really
funny I just love the fact that even
when Jake figures out a way to tell Finn
he's done well it's not just that Finn's
kind of like a doofus Oh cats meow yeah
Shh what I think that's something where
it sounds strange but I kind of got that
because like when you're I don't when
you're a kid there's something that when
like just naturally you want to do the
opposite of what somebody's telling you
yeah so some go you just naturally
in you know don't I have to want to go
louder knows he's getting louder
exactly so yeah so I like that again
still very much feeds into the fact that
you know he's a kid and ya know I really
liked it how would you okay I love MIMO
and I think for me it's the voice it's
really the whole yeah the voice is I'm a
million times with you on that if it's
somehow if it's just cute adorable
little kids voice saying these horrible
things it's just I love it I love the
animation when he's fighting when me and
I was fighting with Finn we're like
where he goes and he kind of whoa kind
of like that yes well he's running
around Finn and you know why Julie what
did you get here there we go
anyway and when he's and when he's
running up around that tree it was
really neat because you I don't know it
just it felt at the same time like
really long and extended but all also
happening at the same time and it was a
really great it seemed to me very bug
ish like he's like this bug going yeah
she it's a she is well she yes sorry it
was kind of just a really great way to
kind of say all right me Mao is really
tiny without just animating it with
everything giant and tight
Little Nemo it was a really neat way to
show it another way the camera would
follow her around and around fish I
really liked that line when when she
cuts his cheek and says you know you're
only make to be able to cooler well it
reminded me a lot of conquest of
cuteness where yeah well over the cow
over like the hill comes a giant looking
guy by the time it gets up to Finny
punches and it's like not even knee-high
it's kinda like Nemo you see like she
goes ah
and then finally gets to Jake and say
okay just a little like paper cut up
look it's like oh that's right he
doesn't mean that was really tiny as it
remind me uh in fellowship of the Ravens
total subject change but just like when
Liv Tyler like at some when she's riding
the horse and then like she hits a
branch and she gets a little cut on the
side of her cheek it's like okay you
just didn't I do look cool you didn't
fight anyone you didn't really I mean
getting a big certify or anything but
you know Oh a bridge oh so in the
trailer when she says coming to kill a
man she can look bad after she has
enough sky right there how'd you get
that scar pin it was a fight I gotta see
this movie movie stuff like that
troll 3 oh my god people dead I mean
come on all of which are not Adventure
Time related that's true but unlike Liv
Tyler's character at least you know Finn
is a badass and he gets those scars and
all those wounds those guys not just by
bumping into a tree so what'd you think
Julie oh yeah yeah it's I agree with you
on the whole it's annoying when
someone's like I have to do this because
if I don't this is gonna happen to any
of you but at least with this one what I
love is Jake is literally kind of caught
because the killer is in his nose he
does one thing wrong the killers go
you're dead all the other ones where
it's like oh no you can't do anything
because I'm holding plank hostage or
this is possibly going on over there
it's like no the killer is literally in
his nose I can't like - when she keeps
injecting him
poins eating sicker in the other grades
try better hey you guys this Oh actually
one of my favorite scenes is where
wildberry princess and Finn come in and
Jake's like yeah maybe it wouldn't be so
bad if you died like you know it is
something I Wanda a lot like these later
adventure ties this time I want to run
across yet then what the last shot in
this is this bird flying and they see me
mouth behind the bird I'll say to myself
if this was kind of like the older
adventure time they would just show they
would just show the bird flying and
that's it nothing yeah
can we just same with a random bird fly
and we don't get quite as much of that
in the later episodes uh and I'm
wondering if that's something where it's
like do you think they started off like
sir with this kind of sense of humor and
not to say they have a totally different
sense of humor but where it really was
random then they decided to put this
story and or do you think it was sort of
planned for the beginning you know I
could sit there and be one of those
people online that's like you know oh my
god they totally had this plan from the
beginning but no I think it was more
season one they had like an overall
concept they liked but there's a lot of
like bizarre things they wanted to toss
in and as it's gone along they're
growing along with Finn in a sense like
okay you know what not like Oh Finn's
now 14 we should totally do blank it's
more like okay you know what for this
season I think we're going to pull back
on the bizarreness of the endings and
have a little bit more of an overarching
storyline it's almost like they're
maturing along with it you know it seems
to me like when you have a show you want
to keep going you can't just do the same
thing girls yet you know Simpsons or
Family Guy or something like that you
have to do something different yet to do
it from a different angle and it seems
to me like this is a show they want to
keep it going for a while so the best
way to do it is like you said just go
more into the character the maturity in
this background and my guess would be
that they probably did have like the
apocalypse thing like in the back of
their mind like Mabel just put a few
things here and there nah but yeah
like this big backstory with all the
other characters it's like yeah they
probably wrote this and they'll be
playing it's like no let's keep going
like let's see we can keep really
pushing this and like have reasons for
everything yeah I'll tie back in that's
what I'm saying like I think it's almost
like they're maturing along with the
show like some shows get worse as they
go along because well like The Simpsons
the first seasons it's like okay this is
our first we're doing really really good
we're really cutting edge and by now
they're like old people like they should
just like you just die seems like you've
gotten past your you're great seer like
you're great seasons now you're just
kind of now you're just pushing the same
jokes you always have all these
characters have backstories all these
characters have this um the other thing
there's not much more you can really do
with it with like Adventure Time at
least right now you know so little about
the characters backgrounds that they can
do heck almost an entire season for like
each character not season at least
together webisodes and it would still be
fresh for a few seasons well I think
with like with something like Simpsons
or all these sort of shows it's like
okay this character what's their story
what's their background okay god this
character what's his story what's their
background and in this you have their
personalities and their abilities but
you don't know their back or you don't
you have the background of the world and
so it's very slowly revealed and I think
by starting off really goofy ZAR this
renze type humor you know it's just
surreal and nonsense and stuff and then
putting this story in there suddenly the
sucky you in like wait so all this weird
stuff actually kind of has an
explanation well I gotta know what the
hell is causing all this and how this is
all happening so instead of starting
with some deep storyline that started
off with bizarreness and then they're
slowly bringing in the deep storyline
which is kind of like to me that's what
kind of pulled me in more than anything
else was as I was going along it was
like wow okay that actually has meaning
this part was actually referenced in
episode 1 this like it's this really
nice interconnecting thing I don't think
they planned it from the get-go but it's
nice that they kind of go back and they
bring
things that have already been mentioned
and then there's a lot of foreshadowing
I don't know it just feels like it's a
very mature show for kids yeah I'd like
to I mean if we don't know or maybe you
do I don't know by me like with the
creators and stuff I mean we don't know
if they did plan this on the beginning
or if they didn't whatever I would like
to think what you say that they didn't
because I like the idea that you can
start with something and you can keep
evolving it you keep adding on top to it
and you can make it stronger you can
make it better and you know again unlike
something like Simpsons that runs the
course I'm sorry for hating on The
Simpsons so much uh uh you know but by
saying that runs this course and they
just keep doing the same thing you know
they sort of it seems like Adventure
Time sir ran its course with this sory
of humor it's like okay well now what
else can we do and they're giving this
backstory and making it still funny but
also very different yeah I mean like I
said the ending of this show if this was
the first season this ending would just
have the bird flying and nothing else
yeah but now they're showing that me
miles there she's gonna come back you
know and the story's gonna continue and
you're gonna find out more what's gonna
happen and you legitimately want to know
what's gonna happen
five or six episodes down the line you
know we're in the first one it's like it
you didn't care what happened the next
yeah episodes I want goofy fun stuff so
I like that I like that it like you said
it matures I have to go away but again
no I mean a again you can get peeved if
we're mocking The Simpsons but I'll say
the same thing about Family Guy and I'm
a Family Guy fan it's that once you find
out all the back stories about you know
everyone the character is the town and
all that stuff you can only go so far
before you start retreading everything
you've already done before and the
problem with a lot of these shows us
they do an entire episode based around
one character and you learn everything
about them one good thing that Adventure
Time is doing considering it's an 11
minute format is that it gives you bits
and pieces bits and pieces bits and
pieces to slowly build up that character
instead of giving an entire episode no
when you paste it together by the time
you learn their entire backstory it's
gonna be like an hour-long episode per
character but they're only giving it to
you in tiny little bits and pieces which
I think works a lot better it makes you
want to come back and see everything
yeah now once you learn the backstory of
Otto you're not going to kind of really
care the next time I talk about Otto's
back story because it's already been
stated I need to know more about Otto's
history and his future what will happen
to Otto will he drive the bus more and
return to the status quo but I mean we
can say that in a sense like almost
market but it's like look at some of the
characters we actually really enjoy in
this they're kind of background
character sometimes sometimes they're
kind of like yeah okay Lady Rainicorn
what does she really do we really like
her but it's like she's almost on the
level as Otto
she's a background character that kind
of has a bigger part than she probably
should have and I love ready to be Lady
Rainicorn don't get me wrong but it's
like back in the good old days of The
Simpsons it's like Otto Otto is just
awesome this is great you know I'm
wondering 10 years from now we're gonna
look back and go I'll leave any corner
Oh God what were we thinking yeah she
seems funny now takes dating her so
clearly something clearly there's
something to I'm like Lady Rainicorn I'm
just saying how times change I'm just
saying that well like I said it yeah
it's a different show now than it was
when it started
oh yeah and I but I think that's a good
thing you know well I like you said that
bed is evolving it is maturing by the
time you get to season five it's evolved
even more yeah so and I'm looking
forward to so thank you thank you
no thanks to you thank you don't you
thank her thank you don't thank her
taking my cutie patootie back I never
want it it's cute on you
no not me damn sure I thought it was
kind of cute on them no that's okay I
still love you it's okay it's okay
don't you touch me there young man
what'd I tell you about 90 spots